[Music]
you have a big issue with twerking
you've been bothering you you think
there's too much of it it's got to stop
especially when you don't have nothing
to twerk you know I mean if you got if
you missing the T and the W and you just
lurking you know I'm saying got nothing
right right you think if there is
someone's got to have a little meat on
their bones to be twerking yeah if not
you gonna start a fire I didn't think of
it that way yeah
now is this true I read that your son
could sing straight out of Compton at
the age of two that he knew the lyrics
to Straight Outta Compton is that true
yes he did not a lyrics espera Conte in
the hole all the lyrics well you know he
was saying everything except the
profanity it was the craziest thing you
know he'd be rapping and he he like edit
his self yeah yes funny that's so cool
he knew not to say the profanity in the
song yeah is that because there's no
cursing in your house not barred kids
the kids are not allowed to curse in the
house not so you can curse who are we
who are we mad at right now
I'll be mad I'm with you I get a
paycheck me and I get paid for this so
no so you guys curse
there's adults curse in the house but
kids what do you you tell them you tell
them they're not allowed to curse that's
how look I don't care what you doing
around your friends you're not I mean if
you wanted to be around your friends you
want to cuss up a storm so be it long as
no adults eat you know I mean if the
adults hear you you in trouble so that's
not that's that's interesting they're
allowed to swear just as long as no
adults hear them yeah cuz they're gonna
do it anyway so you might as well tell
them how to do it when they do it so
that's what we do you know I need to I
need to get advice from you about when
to do it how to do it I do it wrong I'm
sure I'm the coolest dad in America so I
know behind there yeah cool sad America
we'll take a break
you